As an entrepreneur you can lose many different
things.
You can lose money.
You can lose a great employee, a great sales
rep, a big deal, a big client, a big vendor,
a great partner.
You can lose a great attorney, a great accountant.
You can lose many different things.
It's going to be painful.
Don't get me wrong.
It's going to hurt.
It's going to sting.
But if you lose this one thing, this is the
kiss of death.
Let me tell you.
It is the kiss of death above all.
It's the kiss of death.
I remember when I was at a fight with Manny
Pacquiao, he was fighting Marquez.
I don't know if you remember that fight.
And Manny Pacquiao, for the longest time,
it didn't matter who he fought, you would
just look at this guy.
He was like a hungry pit bull.
He was just ready to go after you.
You would look at the guy's eyes and think,
"This guy's going to kill him."
And when I watched him in the Marquez fight,
his eyes were too smiley.
He was too loose.
And he went and fought, and Marquez caught
him.
He fell out.
I was sitting right next to his wife; his
family invited me.
And I was right there.
When he got knocked out, I was sitting there
saying, "Oh my gosh.
What just happened here?"
He lost his edge.
His edge was gone.
If there is one thing you don't ever want
to lose, it's your edge.
And I'm going to tell you exactly what your
edge is.
Look, many, many years ago, I was competing
in a financial services firm, and I was going
against this girl.
When I went to Chicago, and these guys started
saying things about this one girl and this
one other guy.
You know, "this girl.
. . this guy.
. ." all of this other stuff.
And I said, "You know what?
I've been around the marketplace for such
a long time, now as an entrepreneur.
I've seen the most impressive guys, speak
very well, incredible background.
Ridiculous degrees, from the most flamboyant
universities with names and Yale and Ivy and
Harvard and all this type of mess.
I've seen them great last names, great families,
great market, great pedigree, incredible wife,
incredibly good looking, well-spoken, sharp.
I've seen every single thing.
I would say, "this guy's impressive."
Until eventually I realized, having been in
business a long time, I got up on stage and
said, "Look, this girl's sharp, she's got
a lot of things going on."
That was my opening line.
"But there is one thing she's missing, that
she will know in the next 3-5 years."
After my talk everyone wanted to know the
one thing.
And I didn't tell anyone what the one thing
was.
One thing she's missing.
And I knew, because as an entrepreneur, as
an athlete, you see it so many times.
The moment this goes is the kiss of death.
And that edge is your energy.
When your energy goes, everything goes.
Everything goes.
I did a video a couple of weeks ago about
the two different things that you have to
have as an entrepreneur.
I talked about the leadership fatigue factor,
and the leadership endurance factor.
Fatigue, you get tired too early, and endurance,
you can't last too long, stamina.
So how do you create this?
Because when you're an entrepreneur and you
want to come out with the ideas, and all of
a sudden, it's late, it's late, it's late,
it's late (yawn).
. . you're not coming up with ideas any more
because you're tired.
So you're energy's lows.
It's not producing ideas any more.
So if this energy goes, you lose your edge.
100% you lose your edge.
If you're in war, and you're at the enemy
lines, and all of a sudden your energy is
down, you're tired, even if you're tired,
to protect your buddy, he gets shot and is
gone.
Even if you're tired, and you look this way,
boom, somebody hits you and you're gone.
Even if you're too tired and all of a sudden
you're getting up like this, boom!
They hit your helmet and you're gone.
It's the same exact thing with business.
You've got to have these things up.
You've got to be ready to have that idea.
You've got to be ready to have that energy.
So there are certain signs when you look at
it and the first thing I can tell you is this.
I had one of my good friends who flew in and
he and I were sitting and talking and I sat
him in the car, and we were driving and the
last thing asked him before we left the car,
I said, "Let me ask you a question.
How is your energy?"
And he said, "What do you mean?"
I said, "How is your energy?"
And immediately, he gave me this answer.
He said, "Oh yeah, you know, I just started
working out and I just started this."
And by the way, I love this guy.
He's family to me.
And if he's watching this, he knows who he
is.
And I said, "He knows his energy is gone."
He knows it's not the best it's been.
He knows he's let his energy go away and he
feels it.
The moment this energy thing you let loose,
which has a lot to do with what?
Diet, food, exercise, edge, all these -- the
moment you let that go -- listen, let me tell
you.
There are no feelings in the world of competition.
You better believe that Oklahoma State that
just beat San Antonio Spurs, they do not feel
sorry for Tim Duncan.
I guarantee you that they're not feeling sorry
for Tim Duncan.
And I guarantee you, when Tim Duncan beat
out a bunch of other teams who were older
and he was younger, I guarantee you that he
doesn't feel sorry.
In a world of competition, if your energy
goes, everything goes with your edge.
Everything goes.
And I know one thing that has always been
honest to me.
You know when you play the game of poker?
One of the best things about playing a game
of poker, playing a game of blackjack is purely
math.
If you know math, you're going to do good
in blackjack.
If you're not good in math, you're not going
to do good in blackjack.
For instance, sitting on a soft 17, even if
you've got a 16 and if the house is showing
17, and he's got a 7 showing at the top and
you've got a 6, do you hit?
Do you stay?
If he's got a face and you've got a 6, do
you stay?
What do you do with that?
You've got to hit it because it's math.
So blackjack is a lot of mathematical type
of a game.
But the reason why poker is so famous, so
popular is because you're going against another
person, and it's the eyes.
The eyes tell you everything about energy.
The eyes tell you every single thing you can
think about of energy.
So let me tell you what energy looks like.
When energy is high, ideation is high.
When energy is high, sales is high.
When energy is high, your spirit of competition
is high.
Think about it when you talk to somebody who
is 80 years old.
A grandfather.
Ask them questions.
They'll generally say something like this.
"Oh yeah, you know, it's great, it's fine."
Why are they like that?
Is it because they're now very, very wise
and they're no longer competitive?
No!
I knew an 88, 89-year old CEO of MGM who was
still doing deals at 90 years old.
But he exercised and did all this other stuff
because he had his edge.
He had his energy.
John Wooden was 99 years old, and was still
coaching people because he had his energy.
If you let your energy go, you completely
lose your spirit of competition.
You don't want to compete any more.
You're tired.
When people don't want to have a business
or be an entrepreneur, "Oh, you guys are just
too competitive."
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You've lost your energy, sir.
You've lost your energy.
You've lost your edge.
Because there was a time when you were 8 years
old, and you better believe that you were
competitive.
What happened?
I've got 2 boys and they're competing all
the time.
I didn't teach them competition.
They're competing all the time.
You know why?
Their energy is high.
They're competing.
I'm going to do it faster.
I'm going to do this.
I'm going to do that.
When I energy goes, we become wise.
We're no longer competitive.
Nonsense!
You lost your edge is what you've lost.
You need your edge back.
You've got to get your groove back.
You've got to get your grove back is what
you've got to get.
You can do it.
You lose your sense of urgency.
Oh we can do it tomorrow.
Energy's gone.
Oh, we'll do it next week.
Oh, later.
Energy's gone.
Oh.
. . energy's gone.
There's no more urgency.
Energy's gone.
And then drive.
You lose your drive.
There's no longer that drive to get stuff
done.
Ambition's gone.
You don't have that any more.
You don't feel it any more.
You'll see a lot of times when somebody loses
their edge, they lose their energy, standards
drop.
Expectations drop.
Level of performance drops.
You don't have the same standards of people
because your own personal standards have dropped.
The moment your own personal standards have
dropped, you can't hold other people at high
standards.
The moment your own personal standards, personal
expectations have dropped, you can't hold
other people at that level of expectation.
You just cannot.
The moment yours is high, you can raise everybody
else's.
You know, just recently Toronto Raptors were
playing the Miami Heat.
I wanted Miami Heat to win.
Why?
Because I wanted Kawhi to face LeBron.
It would have been a good match up.
But there was one game where Lowry played,
and he was doing terrible, just terrible,
back to back.
Every channel you watched, he's not doing
this, he's not doing that.
That night, the game is over.
It's dark at the arena.
Everyone's out of the stadium, the cleaning
crew.
Everybody's gone.
The lights are left on a little bit, and there
was one guy shooting shots for a couple of
hours.
His name was Lowry.
He's shooting shots.
He's practicing his 3-point shot because it's
not going in.
You know what happens in game 7?
They win; he scored 35, 36 points and they
won the game.
See, that is, I'm going to get better tonight.
I'm going to raise my expectation tonight.
And they win the series because of him.
That's the edge.
The energy when you have it, you lift everybody
up when your energy is high.
If your energy is low, you cannot elevate
anybody around you.
That's your edge that you've got.
Now, a couple of things to keep in mind.
When you go to Las Vegas, you see the wind
turbines.
And what they're doing is they're turning
potential energy into energy.
If they're not turning, you see this in Vegas
and Palm Springs, you can sit there and do
nothing with it.
There's no energy being created.
But because these things are turning, turning,
turning, they're producing energy, electricity
for the entire city.
That's energy being created.
You and your people around you have potential
energy.
A leader brings out the energy.
But the leader leads with the energy.
The leader has the edge, and they feel it.
Everybody around you feels your edge.
You don't think they do, but everybody around
you feels your edge.
Every single person.
Every single person sees your edge.
So this is why when I mentor or coach somebody,
I remember one time me and a couple of our
friends, we were in San Diego and were having
dinner at this real nice restaurant.
We were right by the water and were having
dinner and were talking.
I mentored these guys, a couple out of Houston,
quality people.
And they said, "Pat, you know, we just want
to be the biggest, we want to be this.
we want to be that."
I said, "Listen, you've never made a quarter
million dollars or a half a million dollars.
How do you know that?
You don't know it yet."
We're going to learn if this is all about
money for you or not.
"No it's not."
We'll find out.
We will find out.
Because I've seen a lot of guys that talk.
Now they're continually growing themselves.
Like a better diet, look better, reading non
stop, their faith is incredible.
They have their edge.
Their energy is definitely up here.
But I look at a lot of people and the moment
they hit a certain income milestone, they
slow down.
Because it was never about them winning and
being the best ever.
It wasn't about purpose.
It was just about money.
You see them slowing down.
You see them getting casual.
You see them not improving any more.
You see them losing their edge.
You see them losing their energy.
Because it was never about money.
That's why I know, most people you compete
with, most people's goals are simply tied
to dollars.
So if you want to ask yourself a question
about the edge, here are a couple of questions
ask yourself.
Do you remember when you first chose to become
an entrepreneur?
Do you remember that day?
Do you remember when you first got excited
about what it is to be an entrepreneur?
Do you remember?
Because I remember that day.
I remember when I came home and said, "Dad,
I'm going to do something here with this business
that I think we're going to be free."
I said, "Dad, I'm going to make 10 grand in
a month."
My dad said, "No one's going to make 10 grand.
You're not going to make 10 grand a month.
No one in our family makes 10 grand."
I said, "Dad, I'm going to make 10 grand a
month."
And I remember how excited I was, as a new
person, as a new entrepreneur.
You couldn't stop me from working.
I was so excited.
I remember the first time my dad saw me walking
up on stage and winning.
It was the first time I ever saw my dad cry,
it was December 15, 2003.
I remember the date!
I got up on stage, I got this, we were at
the Queen Mary ballroom and I was looking
at the guy and he was in tears.
Tears coming down his eyes because I didn't
want to have my dad work at a 99 cent story
any longer.
I didn't want him to work there any more.
And this morning my dad had an angioplasty
where they went in and found that one of his
arteries was shut 90%.
Luckily we did it today because he was having
a hard time and they put a stent in there
and they opened it up and he's now doing much
better.
I spoke to him right after the surgery.
But I remember that day.
Let me tell you.
I can say this story today, tomorrow, 10 years
from now, I still get the chills.
I remember when my dad and I went to Hawaii
for the first time.
We had nothing, Iran war, home.
. . NOTHING.
1.8 g.p.a. 99 cent store.
I joined the military.
There is nothing crazy special about the Bet-David
family to nobody.
Until this guy [touches chest] realizes what
it is to be an entrepreneur and everything
I wanted in my life was linked to my energy.
Every single thing in my life that I wanted
was linked to my edge.
Every single thing was linked to this dude's
[points to self] edge and having the energy.
The moment this dude [self] was going to lose
that, kiss it goodbye.
It's the kiss of death.
Now I see that for my dad, I see it on my
son's face; my oldest son is 4-year's old.
And he's got those eyes.
Man, the guy's like on fire all the time at
4-years-old.
This kid was a leader from the day he was
born.
He's fierce.
He knows what he wants.
I look at my 2-year-old and no matter what,
if I go to the bathroom and come out, he smiles
at me again.
I look at him and melt.
We're expecting a kid this week, any day,
it could be tonight, tomorrow, baby's due
on Friday.
Man, I get fired up with that.
So for you, first test is if you can't tell
the story to yourself of when you first became
an entrepreneur and get excited like you were
day one, you've lost your edge.
If you can't look at your customers or your
employees, your staff, your new agent, your
new sales force, your new executives, and
you can't look at them and paint the picture
of where you're going with the same exact
energy and enthusiasm and edge like you once
used to have, you're losing your edge.
If you can't look at your customers and tell
them how amazing it's going to be, you're
losing your edge.
If you can't sit there and tell your people
you love them and care for them, and inject
belief in them, again, your teammates, your
staff, they're going to go through a difficult
time at times.
You're losing your edge.
You are losing your edge, if you can't do
those types of things.
If you can't sit there and create strong relationships
with people to go into business with you because
you've lost.
.. you're losing your edge.
So how do you get it again?
Re-engage!
Get emotional!
Get upset!
Have a private conversation with yourself.
Ask yourself, "What the hell is going on with
you?"
And start leading again.
Start exercising again.
Drop a few things from your habits.
Drop a few things from your diet.
Stop that sugar craving you have in the middle
of the night.
Stop eating that food.
It makes you tired.
It makes you lethargic.
Move your body a little bit.
Shake this thing.
Wake up every single morning and do 100, 200
push ups.
Do 200 sit ups in the morning.
Walk around the house.
Take the stairs.
Stop taking the elevator in the mall.
Stop taking the elevator anywhere if there
is a stair option.
Just start moving your body.
Start increasing this thing [touches head].
You know sometimes when you eat too much heavy
food, this brain is like fried.
Don't eat it!
Change it.
And you'll get your edge again.
Get excited about why you're doing this business
again.
Get excited about what you're doing your venture
for.
Get fired up about it.
But if there's one thing I can tell you that's
your kiss of death, is losing your energy.
You lose your energy, you lose your edge.
You lose your edge, you're no longer needed
in the boardroom.
You're no longer needed in the negotiation
room.
You're no longer needed to get up on the stage
and fire people up.
And by the way, it has nothing to do with
age.
Don't let anybody fool you with that.
Oh, you're getting old, this is natural, this
is what happens.
Bullshit.
Who said that?
I want to meet the person who said that.
Because it's B.S.
Energy is not linked to that.
I know people 80 year olds who have more energy
than 22 year olds.
You want to talk about how healthy they are.
Now of course there's a little bit of the
body that shuts down, but how much of it?
You want to use that as an excuse to sit home
and watch t.v.?
Of course you're energy's going to go low
if you just sit there and not move your body.
Move!
do something with it.
The world's waiting for you to bring out your
full capacity.
That's what's on my mind today.
So the kiss of death, get that energy back
up.
I could talk about this stuff all day long
because when I have one-on-one conversations
and look at somebody I'm mentoring and coaching
and their eyes and say, "Oh, this guy's lost
it.
Oh, he's lost it!
Look at that!
Eyes are droopy.
I see it.
Eyes are a little bit all over the place,
and he can't focus on me any more.
What happened to those eyes?
I remember those eyes five years ago.
You've got $600,000 in the bank now, that's
what you got.
Oh, you've got a million one in the bank now.
Oh, you're driving a nice car now.
Oh, that's what it is now.
Okay, got it.
Hey!
remember the twinkle.
Get that thing going again.
The twinkle again.
The edge again."
Anyway, look, the formula is very easy.
Write your goals and dreams down again.
Don't just link them to money.
Link them to something that has to do with
you living and until the day you die, you
can do that, that's totally fine.
Link it to that.
And then you'll notice a big difference in
the way you're performing.
And you can change that right now, by the
way.
Not next week, two months from now.
Wait until I start exercising.
No no no.
Right now.
Finish this video right now and go do some
push ups right now.
You done watching this right now?
Go run.
If this video doesn't make you want to go
outside and run a little bit or walk around
a little bit or do push ups or sit ups?
Its the waste of a video.
Turn off the t.v. and move around.
If you're at work right now, turn off this
whole thing and go downstairs and walk around
a couple of blocks around your office and
then come back and get to work.
Look at the way you're going to talk on the
phone.
You'll see the difference.
even Mario leg is going nuts right now watching
this camera.
I've got a favor to ask you.
Our goal is to get to 100,000 subscribers
with this channel by August 31.
I even got a pillow.
YouTube.
SUBSCRIBE to this channel, if you haven't
already.
We need 100,000 subs.
I'm about to launch a very big project, we
just bought a domain for lots of money, I'll
be introducing to you guys what that domain
is and what we'll be launching in the next
four months, the third week of August.
We'll be launching something massive around
the world.
It's a very, very big project that we'll be
launching, but we need 100,000 entrepreneurs
to be following this by August 31, so please
share the videos and invite others who are
entrepreneurs like you as well to subscribe
to this content because you'll know why in
the next 3 1/2, 4 months why I'm asking you
to do that.
I love the fans, I love the people that follow
this channel.
I love the questions you guys are asking.
I'm trying to get to all of you as much as
I can.
Some of you on Facebook, some of private message
regularly, I get emails, but especially to
the YouTube channel we're very committed to
this so thanks for all that you guys do with
this channel as well.
I love the feedback and the commentary we
get from the loyal, loyal fans we have at
Valuetainment.
With that being said, if you're watching this
video on another website, you can always to
go PatrickBetDavid.com and see all the content
there as well.
Take care everybody, bye bye.